the only thing better than celebrating
new year's eve is getting to celebrate
it twice and you can do just that at
re-raw irish pub inside the shops at
mandalay place and here to tell us more
about this year's epic double
celebration is jennifer spriggs jennifer
thank you for being here thank you for
having us julian thank you we were just
talking before this interview about how
exciting it is that we're already into
the holidays and you guys have been busy
at re-raw and you're making it fun this
year by celebrating early and at
midnight let's talk about the
celebrations we are so excited to be one
of the first places to celebrate the new
year we are launching an irish new year
at four o'clock this will be the 11th
year that we have done that and our band
will go on stage at 3 30 to play for a
full hour and celebrate the new year and
ring in the new year for the first time
on the strip for 2022. so if people come
in at three or four o'clock do you think
they can make it until midnight are they
fitting both in we're gonna have to wait
and see our band will be back on stage
at nine o'clock the black donnelly's and
they'll play until 11 excuse me they'll
play until one and then we have of
course our food to keep everybody going
in case they are still hungry up until
12 30 and then we'll keep it going all
night long yeah well you have all the
traditional drinks and foods i told you
i've been to re-raw a few times and i
always feel like i'm on vacation when
i'm in there is that the vibe that you
guys like to create like even though
you're on the las vegas trip you feel
like you're in the heart of ireland we
definitely want to take you back in time
and keep you in ireland for as long as
possible you can pour the perfect pine
of guinness you can enjoy one of our
signature fish and chips or shepherd's
pies so it's all about taking you to
ireland and enjoying the full new year
at four o'clock we're excited to ring in
2022. well you're making me hungry
talking about all that good stuff i love
it and if people want to come celebrate
do you recommend reservations or can
they just walk in or how does it work
reservations are always recommended you
can do that by calling the pub or of
course on open table we also will have
walk-ins available so we take everybody
all the time we're happy to have them
and be ringing in the new year and
you've been with re-raw basically since
it's beginning at this location and just
as a final wrap-up here what are you
hoping people take away from your new
year's eve celebration and i mean
everyone's just there to have fun right
absolutely we want everyone to come and
enjoy enjoy the live music and all of
our irish experience and just take you
in and start the new year fresh so we're
excited to have you guys and hey if you
like to go to bed early you don't want
to make it till midnight i'm liking this
4pm time there you go i might just have
to come venture over there so go check
out rera irish pub at the shops at
mandalay place and you can enjoy all the
fun drinks and food thank you so much
for being here thank you